[Music]
good evening welcome to Washington I'm
Bret Baier President Trump is taking on
practically all comers tonight via
keyboard the president rallying against
in no particular order
the late Senator John McCain former Vice
President Joe Biden the Muller
investigation even some of my colleagues
here at Fox News but the president is
particularly upset at critics who he
says are blaming him for a white
nationalist terror attack in New Zealand
it is on that subject that we begin
tonight with chief White House
correspondent John Roberts live Allah
knows long even John Brandt good evening
to you he really has been using Twitter
is something of a Gatling gun lately
with almost 60 million followers one
presidential tweet goes an awful long
way and as you say the president has
been pretty prolific over the last few
days but there is one thing in
particular that has his attention
President Trump was on defense today
lashing out against critics who
suggested a connection between the
president and the New Zealand killer
tweeting quote the fake news media is
working overtime to blame me for the
horrible attack in New Zealand they will
have to work very hard to prove that one
so ridiculous the killer did mention
President Trump in a hate-filled screed
that he posted online hailing the
President as a symbol of renewed white
identity and common purpose the
president is not a white supremacist I'm
not sure how many times we have to say
that with foxes Chris Wallace yesterday
acting chief of staff Mick Mulvaney had
his bosses back rejecting any common
ground between the president and the
killer on immigration that's just absurd
to say that there's some type of
connection between between being against
illegal immigration which is what the
veto was about for legal immigration and
the the ruthless livestreaming of murder
of 15 people that the two things have
nothing to do with each others president
Trump had a particularly active Twitter
weekend firing off twenty nine original
tweets taking a shot at the late Senator
John McCain last in his class for
sending the fake dossier to the FBI and
media hoping to have it printed before
the election he indemnified as usual
daughter megan mccain fired back first
on twitter then
this morning on ABC's The View he spends
his weekend obsessing over great men
because he knows it and I know it and
all of you know it he will never be a
great man the president also took aim at
General Motors over the Lordstown Ohio
plant closing demanding CEO Mary Barra
sell it or do something quickly she
blamed the UAW Union the UAW David Green
was singled out for saying some Trump
supporters may be having second thoughts
about him after several big closures in
Ohio some folks I know have switched
gears right and thought you know when he
came here and said all these great
things that you know they were on board
with that and people are starting to
wake up and for good measure the
president ripped Fox News where Green
was appearing with the Muller report
expected any moment President Trump
today highlighted a USA Today poll that
found 50 percent of Americans agree that
Robert Moeller's investigation is a
witch hunt
very few think it's legit we will soon
find out question mark but there are new
questions whether the report will end
the Moller investigation particularly
since robert muller has asked to delay
rick gates sentencing while he continues
to cooperate with the special counsels
office what were US Attorney Preet
Bharara believes there may be more ahead
but I think people should view with some
skepticism the notion that gets
breathlessly reported every week that
the mother investigation is coming to an
end you might expect other indictments
other work going forward but Barrera did
say that it also is possible that the
special counsels office could be
shuttered if like Michael Cohen the
investigation surrounding Rick gates are
handed off to other districts like the
timing of the release of the Moller
report no one on the outside really
knows right John Roberts loved the North
Lawn John thanks